so with that
uh let me go ahead and introduce a non
so a
is an experienced product manager with
many years of experience here in silicon
valley working for major companies like
zynga and dropbox
in addition to being a practitioner what
makes him unique is that he's also
a teacher of product management he's
been teaching a very popular course
here at stanford for about four or five
years with uh
with his uh partner in crime jz and then
in addition to that they
recently created an online self-paced
program for the stanford center for
professional development that's
available you should see a little link
there if you want to check
out more about that and we'll talk about
it at the end as well
so with that i'm actually going to just
hand it over to another and then and uh
we'll get to your questions at the end
thanks thank you
thank you pax all right thank you
everybody for joining us today
um we're going to spend the next 30 to
40 minutes
talking about one of the most common
mistakes that that i see
in product management and it's really
under this theme of how to build what
your customers want and what your
customers need
so pat shared a little bit about my
background i'll just share a couple more
notes before we dive in
i've been working in product management
in silicon valley for
coming up on 15 years i did my undergrad
and my graduate degrees at stanford
ended up as a product manager at singa
running product management for
the awards with friends franchise for a
few years moved to another startup
called dropbox was there for almost
three years
uh running a business product uh moved
to another company called gusto another
company called pilot
uh and i moved my way from a product
manager to a vp of product over the past
ten years
um so i both manage product management
teams as an executive as well as been an
individual contributor
and the reason that we're doing this
webinar today is
we want to take some of the common
mistakes and common
skills that we teach to our product
managers that we hire
and teach them to everyone there's no
magic in product management
is a practical practiceable skill and a
teachable skill
so the goal of today is to help give you
some information around
the most common mistakes that we see in
the product management
so uh let me start off with uh what i
think is a very common
uh thing to see from someone in the
product management discipline
uh you are talking to a customer you're
talking to someone in the audience
uh and you get a request someone
conducting says hey
it would be really great if uh this
existed what if we did x what if we did
why would it be cool if this thing
existed
um and you go and you do it you spend
six months or a year
and hundreds of thousands of billions of
dollars to develop something and it
doesn't work
and you push this product out to your
audience um it hasn't mixed results it
doesn't achieve the goals that you want
and you're sort of back to score one
where you started this is by far the
most common
mistake that we see in product
management and the reason that it
doesn't work
is it's getting some really important
parts of the process backwards
and i'll explain some core concepts in a
minute but
the the fundamental mistake that's
happening in a situation like this
is when a customer comes to you and says
hey wouldn't it be great if
you could build this thing you're
delegating product management to your
customer
if you just build exactly what you want
and it's bad because you usually end up
in
one of your places uh one possible place
is you have a product that doesn't
actually solve a problem for anyone
it solves a problem for someone but that
people can't sustain the product it's
the second problem
but more often it mixes together a
number of different problems and doesn't
try and do anything in particular
um so i mentioned this over and over but
this is by a very wide margin the most
common mistake that we see in product
management i would say that
more than half of the products that i've
worked out in my career that
ultimately were not successful had some
form of this situation their diagnosis
so today what i'd love to do is
introduce a framework that you can use
to
first notice when you're in this
situation and second fix
when you're in this situation and to do
that
i want to introduce the core concept for
today which is this
notion of something called a problem
space and something called a solution
space
and these are two of the cure concepts
that we teach in our class of stanford
as well as the online class
but let me start off by defining the two
of them talking about the differences
between them
now we can talk about how you can use
them to solve the problem that i
just mentioned let's start off by
defining the problem space
what do we mean when we say problem
space um when we talk about
a problem space in product management
parlance the problem space is the area
where you were talking about the
problem you are solving for the customer
who your customer is
and why it's important to them and
nothing else there is no discussion of
how you're going to solve the problem
you are entirely focused only on
understanding your customer and the
world and their problems today
and no energy is going into changing it
at all you're not composing solutions
you're not doing wireframes you're not
drawing pictures
you are only listening this is a really
difficult thing to do it sort of runs
counter to most people's intuitive
notion if you're having a conversation
with a customer and the customer says
i had these problems it's very natural
to want to pitch them well what if we
did this what if we did this
resist those urges and don't do it the
goal of the problem space is again
only to understand things that matter to
your customers
and not to try and present any solutions
to them at all
the best way to do this is with a set of
skills that we call
customer development or customer
research this is again its own
separate and dedicated field if you work
in a larger organization you will often
have dedicated researchers who can help
you with this
it is a craft that can take many years
to perfect
but it's another thing that we teach in
both the online class in our class
at stanford it's again a practicable
skill so if you interview
dozens or hundreds of people you will
get better at doing this disambiguation
almost for free um there's some of the
common tips and tricks they will walk
through
the real important principle here is
you're not to trying you're not trying
to convince
your customer of anything you're not
trying to sell them something
you're not trying to pitch them
something your only job
is to listen and again that's a very
hard skill to do well
um i also want to disambiguate what we
mean by a problem
um and when we say problem uh like
what do we mean uh problem is just any
unmet
need want or desire from a customer so
uh it can be a problem that is real it
can be a problem that's experienced
um all you're trying to do here is
figure out uh
an unmet need from a customer
perspective okay so uh let's
uh do a quick recap just where we are um
and what we're talking about so we
introduced this really core concept of a
problem space and a solution space
and one of the most common mistakes that
i see in product management
is mixing up these two things it's
talking to a customer or talking to
somebody inside your company
and being unclear in your own mind
whether you are trying to figure out
what their problem is
or whether you are trying to pitch them
a solution and the number one tip that
we have for new product managers
is to be very clear about which mode you
are operating am i in a mode where my
job is to understand customers and
research what they care about
or am i in a mode where my job is to
pitch a solution
or a product to customers and again when
we say problem here we say solving a
customer problem
there's a very broad definition of what
we mean a problem is just an unmet be a
desire a want from your customer
um it doesn't need to be something
that's life-changing it can be something
that is entertainment it can be
something that is small
but just in the vagus sense you're
trying to solve an unmet need for
a customer perspective um the other
thing i want to mention that problems
can
very much be real or perceived there
have been a number of
occasions throughout my career where a
customer expresses a problem and it
turns out there is actually a solution
to that problem
they might just not be aware of it or it
might be an internal problem versus an
external problem
so one of the other common mistakes you
see in product management
is telling your customers your problem
is not real if it is real to the
customer it is in fact a real problem
um so the way this gets
interpreted can sometimes be confusing
so
if people are familiar with this quote
which may or may not have been said by
henry ford
um if i asked people what they wanted
they would have said faster forces
this is a quote that gets misunderstood
and i think it gets interpreted as don't
listen to your customers um there's a
little bit of a
myth in silicon valley and the press
that your customers don't know what they
want
and your job as a visionary or as a
product leader
is to ignore what your customers tell
you and give them what they actually
want
i think that's a fallacy um and i think
the misunderstanding is actually just
coming from a subtle
misinterpretation of this quote when a
customer says faster horses
your job is to communicate that what
they're looking for is to get between
point a and point b
in less time and the skill of product
management is to listen to your
customers and interpret
their words into a problem statement
because a customer isn't always capable
of articulating exactly what they want
so definitely don't ignore your
customers and don't
and don't and make sure that you talk to
your customers
but at the same time you can't just
delegate product management to them and
do exactly what they're saying
your job is to interpretation between
their words and their actual needs
so we introduced this notion of a
problem space let me introduce the
contradictory notion of a solution space
um so
problem space again you're only trying
to understand the world of your
customers
whether it's real or perceived the
solutions base is what probably most
people think
of when i think classically a product
management this is where you try and
change something
you build something you prototype
something you design something you're
attempting to
make an attempt to solve the customer's
problem in the first place
so this is sort of the classic thing
that people think of when they think of
product management
wireframes mocks designs that sort of
work
but the key distinction again and the
point that we want to highlight today
is you shouldn't ever mix these two
things you should be very clear in your
own mind whether you're operating in a
problem space or operating solution
space
and don't mix the two of them up um
dilution space very simply put is how
you're going to solve the problem for a
customer
so a prerequisite for the solution space
is understanding the problem space
this is again a very classic mistake
that we see where
someone will come up with the design and
they will go and pitch it to a customer
and they won't have a clear articulation
of what problem they're solving
so the design solves a little bit of a
lot of different
problems it might solve twenty percent
of problem one and twenty percent of
problem two
but when you really look at it from a
customer perspective there is no
overarching synthesis of problems that
it solves effectively so the customer
isn't interested in using it um i think
a good
problem space definition is basically
always a prerequisite for getting to the
solution space
um so if you're working through this in
real life i very much encourage you to
start in the problem space
before moving to the solution space and
this is the place where you very
classically think of building something
so your job here is to build
a real product or wireframe or a
prototype
um so we introduced a couple of key
concepts so far
one is this notion of the problem space
the other is this notion of the solution
space
but there are many other reasons that
the product cannot work but it's totally
possible to have
a real problem from a customer
perspective and a great solution
and still have your product or your
organization fail
so the second thing that we want to
spend a few minutes talking about today
is your job as a product manager is to
figure out
how you can actually capture value from
something that you built
um and the the really simple way of
distilling this is
you can build something that your
customers still love that solves a real
problem for them
and still fail um and i'll pick one
example from recent history but there
are many more examples
i'm not sure if people in the audience
are generally familiar with moviepass
but moviepass was a company that existed
up until a few years ago that for ten
dollars
per month uh in the us would allow you
to watch
unlimited movies for free in theaters
and customers loved it there were
millions of subscribers that signed up
in the first year
so from a customer need perspective it
was very clear that they were doing
something that customers wanted
the problem for moviepass came on the
economic side of things it turns out
then when it cost
ten dollars to see a single movie and
you're selling unlimited movies for ten
dollars a month
the economics make it very difficult to
have a profitable company
so uh this is not to pick on moviepass
in particular
but the thing that i want to highlight
is your job as a product manager is not
only to figure out what your customers
actually want
is to look at the intersection of
customer needs and business opportunity
you'll sometimes hear this phrase uh
product manager for the ceo of the
product or product managers represent
the business need
your job is to bridge these two things
and make sure that you are both
doing something that your customers care
about and something that is economically
sustainable
and the key insight here is that if you
go talk to a customer and you get a
customer problem from them
that does not mean that that problem is
always worth solving
um it could mean that uh the market is
too small for your goals it can mean
that
they care about the problem but they're
not willing to pay for it so there's a
whole
separate track that you need to think
about as a product manager
uh independent of a customer problem is
is there enough
economic value here that this thing is
worth solving
and i mentioned economic value i think
it's important both in the context of
uh for-profit organizations but also for
the context of non-profit organizations
or ngos et cetera
you need to know what your goals are and
figure out whether this thing is
actually sustainable
so what's the difference between a
problem and an opportunity and this is
just terminology that
we teach new product managers when they
join
jay-z's organization or my organization
very simply put
an opportunity is an idea that has been
validated to be good
for both the customer and for the
company so it means you've done homework
on two sides of the problem
it means you've spent enough time
talking to customers that you have a
deep understanding of the problem space
and you spend enough time on both the
strategy and the economics
that you're convinced that this is a
good thing to build for the organization
that you represent
so again just a quick recap the second
very common way that uh
that products can fail is you do build
something that customers want
but you're not able to capture enough
economic value out of it for your
company to be self-sustaining
so we teach a handful of different
flavors for doing this but
what we wanted to introduce today which
is very simply the core concept that
your job as a product manager is to make
sure you are at the intersection
of things that are good for the user and
good for the company and to make sure
you're not going too far and either way
you don't want to be too selfish from a
company perspective
or to altruistic where it's not
sustainable and again not all problems
can actually be solved in a way that
necessarily captures value
your job as a product managers figure
out which is which
so it looks like we have a bunch of
different questions from people in the
audience um
pax what's the best way to to run
through some of the q and a together
because i want to make sure we get
through as many of these as we possibly
can
so we're getting a whole bunch of
different kinds of questions and on so i
i think
maybe the place to start it is coming
back to
how do you surface these problems to
solve so on the one hand
there's you know you're an entrepreneur
you have a product idea that seems
fairly straightforward maybe
on the other hand you know if you're a
product manager you come into the middle
of a cycle
how are you surfacing these problems
what are the best ways to do that
totally um i think it's a bit dependent
on
uh two things one of them is whether you
have an existing product
and existing customers the second is
whether you're starting something from
scratch so let me address each of those
because you can get slightly different
answers
uh if you join an existing organization
or an existing product
some of the work that will already be
done for you is hopefully you already
have
some idea of who your target customer is
and what problem you are solving for
them so if that's the case one of the
very common ways that you build a
roadmap for a product that already
exists
is to go spend time talking to your
either your existing customers
or your next set of customers so if i
make up an example
if your current customer today is you
know businesses with 0 to 50 employees
and you want to target bigger businesses
maybe you would talk to businesses with
50 or 75 employees
so you have to fix something uh in this
equation in order to figure out what
you're doing
and the common things you can fix or you
can either fix your customers or your
market or your goals
um if you're starting a new company um
this you have a very much chicken and
egg problem
you don't have a customer yet you don't
have a product yet um you might have a
goal and you need to figure out
which of these things you want to fix my
suggestion for how to work through these
is to fix the goal first and then the
customer second
because the goals really matter and by
goals i mean what is your
definition of success for your
organization so
two examples if your goal for example is
to start a company that is worth 10
billion dollars
there are many more constraints on
things like the market size
um than there are if your goal is to
start a company that's worth one million
dollars
um and that will disqualify some ideas
that might otherwise be good ideas
um from a customer perspective uh again
this is a bit chicken and egg but my
advice to people is
to fix the customer um and then to try
and fix find a problem for them so it's
a little bit like fixing the market
and then exploring that market to figure
out where that might be an opportunity
this is not the only way to do this you
can do it in the opposite direction as
well
but to your question you need to fix
something in order to figure out
who you can actually talk to to
determine whether something is a problem
and my advice for new companies or for
new organizations
is first think about your goals slash
the market and then think by your
customers and an existing organization
hopefully much of this work is done for
you
great and then we've gotten a few just
in terms of the division of labor here
and
and so we'd be curious to know how you
run it i'm sure there are many different
ways to do it
but if you're a product manager should
you be conducting these interviews
yourself or are you the person who
develops the the questions the problem
to solve
and then uh get someone else to conduct
the interviews what's kind of
what do you see in terms of the general
uh division of labor in terms of these
things and
i'm sure there are many models so if you
could talk through some different ways
to approach that
yeah it's very much dependent on um on
how big your organization is
because as organizations get larger they
end up with specialization and different
dedicated functions
so if you work at a very large company
like google for example
you will have dedicated user researchers
who might be the people who talk to
customers
you'll have designated product marketers
who do a different slice of the product
management work
um so at very large organizations there
tends to be more specialization
and a subdivision of labor between these
problems if you're working in an
organization
called less than 100 or 200 people
then probably the product manager is the
person doing all of this
and your job is both to talk to
customers and synthesize the research
and to write the report
and do the economic analysis so it's
very much dependent on size of
organization
the way that the way that i prefer to
segment it in
my organizations is to try and have as
much information with one person as
possible
so the problem with specialization is if
it takes 15 people
to figure out what somebody wants you
can end up with either designed by
committee
or uh you know one person knowing a set
of things and somebody else not liking a
different set of things
so i think it's very important to have
as much information in one person's
brain as possible so i prefer to keep
the team smaller rather than larger
that's great um and as you surface so if
you're starting
you you've got a problem to solve you
begin to interview customers
how do you kind of validate the solution
space i mean how do you
there's the risk of say um you know a
biased
group of of customers maybe you've only
interviewed 10 to 15 and there is always
a risk that they're
you know an unusual selection so how do
you validate the solutions you're coming
up with
um how do you mix qualitative and
quantitative research to do that
yeah a really good question um so i
would definitely say that
there is no bulletproof way of doing
this the bulletproof way of doing this
is to
build something and try and ship it to
the world um
but that is expensive so the whole idea
of methodologies like
um like an agile methodology early
instead of methodology is to take the
scientific method
and to try and apply them to different
parts of this problem so
uh one way that we do this at my
organization
is to break down your uh your solution
into a set of things that you need to
believe
in order for your solution to be
successful so an example this might be
uh we believe that the market is a
certain size we believe that this set of
customers actually really has this need
or we believe that people are willing to
pay 500
for this product and to try and proves
uh small slices of those things
individually
so let's just be willingness to pay as a
as a random example
if you were these are people willing to
pay for this um you have to do some
infrastructure work with the ability to
accept payments et cetera and then you
can put it out there and see if people
are actually willing to pay for it
so my suggestion is there isn't a there
is not a surefire way to do this
otherwise everybody's product would
always be successful but it's to write
down the list of hypotheses that you
think need to be true in order for your
thing to work
and to try and construct clever ways to
test them in isolation from each other
in particular ways that are cheaper than
building the whole thing
um and what you're trying to avoid is
spending many years or many millions of
dollars up front
researching something and then having it
just not work
that's that's that's fantastic that's
good good
good feedback hard to do i imagine in
practice uh kind of
staying within this problem solution
space we're getting a lot of questions
about other sort of product management
and i do want to move to those
uh at some point but you know could you
tease out a little bit more i think this
is always a challenge
is is teasing out the customers want
from their needs so there is as you said
it's pretty straightforward when a
customer says
hey i think this is what you should be
doing and that's clearly
what the customer wants but in other
cases it could be a little bit more
ambiguous and difficult so
what are some techniques for really
teasing out that the need or the
the real problem underneath the the sort
of language of the user
totally um one of the suggestions i have
is to search for places that are either
wasting time money or like human effort
and there's not a complete set of
solutions
but those are three of the most
classically common things that you you
can
improve from a product perspective so an
example might be if somebody comes to
you and says
i have no problems you'd be surprised
how often this happens um you'd say
great where are you spending your time
i just want to watch a day in the life
in your eight hour a day when you go to
work what do you do
and what you might find out is actually
they spend six hours entering stuff into
excel and they don't consider that a
waste of time but there might be an
opportunity for a product there
um the advice i gave is very focused on
products that are either targeted
businesses or products
products that are targeted sort of
efficiency save money save time sort of
things
it's a little bit harder to do in things
that are consumer-oriented or
entertainment-oriented
um so when i worked in gaming for
example the way we would do this is
we would actually create like fake
posters or fake trailers for games that
didn't exist yet
and see whether people are excited or
interested in it
but i think the goal of the problem
space solution space disambiguation
is to make sure that you are
intellectually honest about which of the
two you are in and know whether you're
trying to
learn something from customers or pitch
something to customers at this moment
in time and never to mix those two
things up
and do you come back when you have a
solution do you come back
and do you pitch i mean how do you or do
you just launch the project i mean what
is
no yes what is this launching it not
pitching it
uh no absolutely you should go back and
this is depending on what your
constraints are
um what is your timeline for example
what is your budget what is your company
culture
um there are companies that do none of
this like apple for example doesn't
really
test any of their hardware in large
public areas there are companies that
run betas for 10 years at a time
so it's a little bit dependent on your
company philosophy but my suggestion for
this
is is better as much as possible to take
it back to your customers and see does
this actually work
that's the reason that uh betas are so
common or alphas which are common or
early access
so i think the general best practice
here is not to just launch something and
hope it works
it's you listen to some set of customers
build something
take it back to those people and see
whether it's actually useful and then
launch it
and so in those cases to see if it's
actually useful you would want to set up
a certain
set of sort of metrics that you're
looking at or would you come back to the
the focus group and interview or is it a
combination
it's usually a combination of both
qualitative and quantitative and part of
this depends on how big you can go in
your
in your beta period um so in some of the
betas that i've run
the beta might have 10 000 people for
example and if the beta has 10 000
people
you can actually do quantitative
measurement you can say how often are
people using this how much time is
spending on et cetera
but if you're selling uh let's say an
enterprise product where the total
number of customers you have is 50
customers
it might be your ability to run really
good analytics on a beta group of five
might be much more limited
um so again it's a little bit of the
tools that you have available based on
your customer and your market
but i would try and pair as much
qualitative and quantitative as you
possibly can
because doing so will decrease your
probability of failure
that's great i want to maybe shift if
you're comfortable with the shift
direction a little bit so i'm kind of
thinking about the next
stage i know one of my biggest
challenges and it's coming up a lot is
prioritizing as you get solutions in
and maybe you have a number of problems
and i know you point to
you can source it from complaints etc so
i wonder if you could talk about two
related things so
maybe first thinking about how you begin
to prioritize
some of the the solutions that you're
coming up with and then the second which
i think is related
is giving us a sense of how do you
estimate risk
uh in terms of pursuing a different i
know you've talked a lot about that i
think that's a really valuable
topic to discuss in the context of
prioritization
sure um so let me start with the
prioritization question and then we can
talk about the estimation question
from a prioritization perspective you
must have some set of objectives that
you are trying to achieve
in order to do prioritization and again
the most common place where i see people
fall down is they don't
they have not agreed on what their
objective but what outcome they're
looking for
so in an organization you might call
this company goals
you might call it vision you might call
it strategy but you must have
free agreement on the set of things that
matter otherwise it is impossible to
prioritization
but you cannot compare disparate sets of
things without knowing which goal is
important
so at the organization that i've run for
example what we will do on either a
three-month cadence or a six-month
cadence
is we will sit down with the executive
team the company and we'll agree on the
goals that matter
and these might be very quantitative a
particular example might be you know we
want revenue to go from a to b
or we want retention to go from b to c
or they could be qualitative
um we want uh uh amazing customer
feedback on something that we launched
etc
but this is a little bit of a like you
just have to agree on it
and there is no right way to do this
like determining whether revenue is more
important than retention is very much a
function of your company your lifespan
the market you're in whether your
venture fund etc and this is the reason
that
uh being an executive is hard so you
have to agree on the set of goals in the
first place
once you agree on the set of goals now
you have criteria to do prioritization
against
and the goal is the ability to say is it
more important to do something that's
revenue moving or something that is
customer satisfaction moving
well we have pre-committed that we care
more about revenue for this quarter than
we care about the other problem
therefore this thing is important
so i think one really important piece
here is you
must know what your goals are before you
can do prioritization
otherwise you will talk in circles
forever and then the second one is
to try and take your projects and group
them into buckets instead of comparing
every project to every other project
so another thing that i see that ends up
taking up a lot of organizational time
is uh if your idea of prioritization is
to take every possible project you could
work on
put them in a giant spreadsheet and
compare it to every other possible
project
and the problem here is the the
combinatorics on this is very large um
and if you have 50 or 100 ideas
it is an impossible thing to reason
about
um so my suggestion for creating
cognitive simplicity here is basically
to create this notion of themes or
buckets where you take projects that
work on similar topics and group them
together
and you prioritize first at a bucket
level and then in a project level
so from a bucket level you might say you
know the bucket of projects talking
about customer satisfaction is more
important than the bucket of projects
talking about revenue
even if an individual project might be
you know higher uh
higher roi something the other bucket
and then you can talk about
well within that bucket these are the
most important projects and what this
does is it creates cognitive simplicity
and like organizational clarity
especially as organizations get larger
one of the most dangerous things is
people being confused about what
actually matters
so a big part of your job as a product
manager to say these are the things that
matter
move in this direction so that's very
much my suggestion on the prioritization
side
and probably the most common one is
having an unclear set of
goals that you actually care about
causing confusion in the organization
for your second question about
estimation i think there's a couple of
different
tools that i use and like estimation for
my prioritization
um there's an infinite number a very
large number of prioritization
frameworks i wouldn't say that any is
like better or more correct than any of
the others
but the two that i use are some notion
of estimating impact and some notion of
estimating cost
um and they're not perfect um but uh
from a
from an uh impact perspective uh some of
the tools we use
are a tool called fermi estimation we're
basically back to the envelope
math to say you know i think that uh if
these set of assumptions held true
the impact to our goals might be x so it
might be
um we could get 700 customers sign up
for this each pay
100 bucks a month therefore revenue
would be wrong
on the cost side of things this is where
you partner more strongly with
your your collaborators an engineering
team
or a design team and saying you know we
have some rough idea of what this thing
looks like
how much do we think this will cost to
build and cost usually is expressed in
time sometimes expressed in dollars
depends on
on the field they're working in but one
of my pieces of advice here is being
very aware of over precision
um like it's very difficult to tell the
difference in a project that might take
you know six weeks and seven weeks for
example i can probably tell a difference
in a project that takes six weeks
and a year so the framework that i use
for most of my project
is hours days weeks months quarters
years
and only placing it in one of those
buckets because otherwise
otherwise you can spend a lot of time
trying to figure out is it six months or
seven months and your ability to predict
that perfectly in advance is
probably not very good the important
thing to know is that a six months not a
year
great i think maybe it would be useful
now to zoom out a little bit we're
getting a lot of questions
um you know about sort of
implementing some of these ideas at the
organizational level so
you know a lot of us will be working in
organizations that don't necessarily
have clear objectives or where many uh
many managers are very much focused on
solutions and not the problem space
so i wonder if you could talk a little
bit about obviously that's probably
bigger
problem than a product manager can
change but how would you work within
that
to begin affecting organizational change
and maybe how would you apply these i
know you talk about this
this framework is not just a something
for
creating products but for solving
problems in general so i wonder if you
could talk a little bit about how you
might
even apply this framework to thinking
about implementing some of these things
at an organizational level
sure that was a complicated question so
it just
yeah the question is how do you how do
you work within an organization that is
does not have clear objectives
or where some of these principles are
not
uh it's harder to follow within them how
do you
navigate that as a product manager
totally
so one suggestion i have if you are
you know a line product manager or
running a small team and you don't have
the ability to get clarity for the
entire organization
is to at least get clarity for the world
that you are familiar with um so maybe
it's going to your boss or the general
manager of your division or your vp or
whatever and saying
you know we may not know the five things
that matter for the company but can we
at least figure out the thing that
matters for my team
so ideally you would create
organizational clarity for the entire
company and cascade it down to all of
the teams
but if that's beyond your control um
your job as a product manager is to make
your team
successful so at the very least one of
the things i would do is
try and get to clarity for your team
whether it's your immediate team or your
group or your division or whatever
um and just pre-committing to it and and
one of the things that i've
found in my experience working on this
problem is that um usually people aren't
unwilling to to give clarity here they
may either just not have thought about
it or the organization may not have
these processes to exist
that exist to push it very clearly to
everybody so i
can't think of an example at least in my
career where you know i ask for clarity
on what matters and we were like
why are you asking this question um but
you may not get the answer for everyone
you might just get the answer for your
subdivision of the company
so i know there's probably an
unsatisfactory answer but
you can't control everything as a
product manager
and i would try and control as much as
you possibly can to either organization
clarity
but if it's not all of the organization
so be it
fair enough that makes sense we're
getting a few questions now
it might pushing into thinking about
product management in other
other respects so do you have is this a
framework that you've seen applied
successfully to
consulting or services industries in
addition to something where you have a
clearly defined
technology product or hardware product
um it depends a little bit on uh
so limited answer yes uh broader answer
is it's more complicated
um i've done some work in consulting for
example and one of the things that uh at
least i found to be true in consulting
is
there were two types of it um type one
of consulting was
you know the client who genuinely did
not know the answer and they like wanted
you to come up with the answer for them
in a scenario like that i found
frameworks like this to be very
effective the second type of consulting
is the customer knows the answer and
they
want you to tell them what they already
know because it creates organizational
alignment or clarity or whatever
in a scenario like that a process like
this may be less useful
um so i don't think this is like you
know this is not a framework that will
solve all of your problems for all
for all industries for every company in
the world but i do think it's a pretty
good
way of thinking about problem solving in
general so whenever you need to solve
some problem for somebody that isn't you
what it does is it forces you to go
through this methodology of first
talking to that person you'd be
surprised how many companies never even
go through the effort of talking to the
person trying to solve the problem for
um sitting and like writing on a piece
of paper what you think the problems are
and what you think success looks like
and only then starting to figure out
what you want to do to solve that
problem
so i do think it's a pretty generally
applicable problem solving framework
um but it will not be i mean this is not
the thing to use for every company in
the world
and how have you seen this how have you
seen in the last nine months
uh through the series of of shelter and
places and
and other disruptions related to uh kova
how have you seen the product management
role change and how do you predict it
if are any of those changes permanent
what is the future of that role
yeah that's a good question um so i
think one thing that's gotten
uh easier is uh is actually talking to
customers it's a little bit
counter-intuitive
but in a prior world where you might fly
somewhere to do customer research
or set something up um things like zoom
or webinars are a little bit more
normalized and it's easier to go to
customers wherever they are
so i've actually seen it get easier to
talk to customers instead of harder to
talk to customers because
what previously might be you know a trip
to la
is now a assume that only takes 30
minutes
i've seen it get harder for product
managers to do
to navigate internal organizational
dynamics because
for better for worse i think product
management often requires a lot of soft
skills and soft sales are very hard to
do over the internet
like it is uh it's a job that requires
being able to go to someone tap them on
the shoulder and ask them a question
or have a hallway conversation or have a
set of in-person meetings
so i think the product management job as
as a
creator of alignment inside an
organization has gotten a little bit
tougher
as as organization
a little bit but the silver lining is
that customers are more willing to talk
to you than ever because many more
people are willing to hop on a 30-minute
video call
that's great that's incredibly helpful
one more question before we maybe talk a
little bit about breaking into it i'd
love to spend maybe
a few minutes on that and then we'll
we'll uh and i see a lot of questions
have come in and we appreciate the
participate
but just for for a sake of time we'll
just get a few more so one question is
uh for those on the call who maybe
aren't product managers but are in other
positions and are trying to understand
the product manager role
is there anything they should understand
about the position of collaborating with
product managers so for instance the
sales team
or um or the engineering team
yeah um i think so one of the things i
have
uh tried with a fair amount of success
is just introducing
this terminology it's like problem space
and solution space
to three teams in particular one team is
like the sales and marketing team the
second is like a customer success or
customer support team and third is an
engineering team
and the reason that has been quite
successful is
um those are the people who spend a lot
of time either talking to customers or
talking to you directly
and they have a tendency to only push
through information in the solution
space
so a really classic example of this
dynamic might be
you know sales team is talking to a
bunch of customers and customers like i
won't buy because you're missing this
feature
so in the old world of salesperson right
now we need this feature and then handle
the product mentioned to you and you'd
say well like what problem are we
solving
for that um so having a sales team for
example know
to ask oh why do we need this feature
what problem are you trying to solve but
what are you trying to do with it
makes that conversation very different
instead of writing down build future x
what the sales team writes down
is you know this thing is their problem
is they're spending too much time on
this or this is too hard to use or
whatever else
and that's a very different conversation
to have and a much more useful
conversation to have
so you're not i mean you're not trying
to teach everybody in your organization
to be a professional product manager
but for people who spend a lot of time
talking to customers i have found
introducing them to this distinction
very helpful because it helps them ask
better questions to customers
so that they can better surface to the
organization
that's fantastic so you're using that
that front line to be kind of
uh the needs finders they're they're
conducting these miniatures
constantly and you're getting much
richer information as a result
uh the chance of being successful as a
company goes up as you get closer to
your customers
so it's not just your job as a product
manager to be close to customers it's
everybody's job so
the the better tools you can equip your
entire organization with fairly our
customers actually care about the higher
chance of success
so the natural follow-up is is for those
those teams that may not be
as customer-facing for instance
uh maybe engineering or even uh content
development how do you
how do you translate or how do you get
them engaged into to the
customer mindset yeah um so
uh i'll just take engineering as an
example one of the things that i found
to be very helpful is
uh if your job is a product if you think
your job as a product manager show up
and tell people what to build
um it will only work so long as you are
right and no one is right all
the time um so you can very quickly
suffer this you know a crisis of faith
or the engineering camp not believe in
you
um but what tends to work much better is
to explain
why you are doing something not just
what you are doing
um so one of the things that i do for
all of uh for all the projects
on in my product organization for
example is
we will basically have a meeting that
exists between the product team and
engineering team that's working on
something
we will sit down and we will walk them
through the problem we're solving
um it doesn't take long you know it's
half an hour and a maybe a six week
project and eight-week project so it's
not a huge time commitment
um but what it does is it solves two
problems first is they understand why
um like it's not just what we're doing
they understand why we're doing it and
the second thing that it does is
it helps them ask better questions um so
if you make a bit let's say you
make a mistake you know halfway through
a project and you're like i think we
should build this
and the engineer is like oh actually i
thought this was the problem we were
solving like well how does this directly
relate to that problem
you can say oh that's my mistake like i
did i was not thinking it through i
forgot what problem or something
so i found that concept to be
extraordinarily useful because
it takes them along the journey that you
have uh
that you have experienced and it
communicates not just what you are doing
but why you are doing it
and the more people that know why you
are doing something the more
intellectual horsepower you can bring to
bear on the problem
instead of people just you know doing
whatever you put into jira
that's great and that's fantastic advice
i i think we're just about at time but
maybe the last question
i do want to mention again that we
there's a link in the
interface where you can check out an
earlier webinar where annon goes in
great
detail about breaking into product man
but i think as we bring this to a close
do you have any thoughts or what are one
or two things
that anyone who's in a different line
within an organization might want to
think about starting to do
if they're interested in transitioning
into a product management role
sure
so uh the unfortunate state of the world
today is that the best predictor of
getting a product management job is
already having a product management job
um and a lot of people it's a lot of
people find it very hard to make a
switch
um i think that there are basically
to i've seen sort of three ways that
people end up in product management
careers they're not responsible for 100
percent of people but probably
responsible for
seven or eighty percent of people that i
know um track
one is going through a structured
program that exists in an organization
so you know the famous ones are like the
apm program at google over the rpm
program facebook
this is not a silicon valley specific
problem though um there are a lot of
organizations that have a
designated internal track it's often two
years
where you hire somebody out of school or
out of an mba program
and you spend a couple of years teaching
them to be product managers
um i very much believe it's a teachable
skill and i think that most of those
most of those are pretty high quality so
if you can end up in one of those
i think that's a great opportunity to do
so the second
is a little bit of a backwards uh path
where you start an organization or you
start a company
you get acquired or uh or your company
is successful whatever and you end up at
some other company as a product manager
it sounds like a weird path to get there
but probably more than a third of the
people i know who are product managers
he
either previously founded a company that
was acquired or found at a company and
there's a reason there's a lot of
overlap between
the founders skills and the product and
interest and then the third
is to be in a position where your job is
to talk to customers on a day-to-day
basis so if you think of the two
like fundamental attributes that i think
product managers should have
um one of them is basically can you be
close to the customer and second is can
you be good at the craft of product
management
um and if you don't have a second i
would think about how you can get first
so teams like sales or success or
support
are particularly good at this because
you spend all day talking to
customers or prospective customers so my
advice to people if they're looking to
make a career change
is basically trying to figure out is
there a world where you can be as close
as possible to your customers
and understand them as deeply as
possible because that's one of the core
jobs of the product manager
perfect i think that's a perfect uh
ending point for for the webinar so anan
i want to thank you for your time and
thank everyone who joined us today
so anan thank you again for your time
and thank you everyone for joining us